Dirk Herschel is an expert for economic
policy at the union Verdi which
represents workers in service industries
and public services welcome to the
program no you don't represent the train
drivers in this case directly but you
are acquainted with strikes and
different types of industrial action
were you affected by the most recent
strike not really it took the
underground train which was not affect
about a strike sir lucky you okay trucks
instead of trains as we just saw in that
report it's more expensive it's less
efficient and there are estimates that
this strike caused German firms hundreds
of millions of euros every day if this
continues are we gonna see German
companies going out of business yeah but
that's part of the game and the right to
strike is a fundamental right and as a
union you have to hurt your employer
otherwise you won't succeed with your
strikes and that's the way it goes ok
well that brings me to the next question
you say you have to hurt your employer
are strikes an effective way to get what
you want from your employer I think so
if you do it in an effective way if you
are able to hurt the employer economic
le he has to negotiate again and our
experience is that we can negotiate
without strikes but if the employer is
not willing to negotiate that's our last
opportunity we have to use so if it
hurts it works now this latest strike
took place over an important weekend
here in Germany it was the 25th
anniversary of the fall of the Berlin
Wall a lot of people were relying on the
train to get where they needed to go and
they couldn't do you think that turned
public sentiment against the strike I
don't think so because they the public
sentiment changed in the last year's in
favor of the union so people in my
country they are they are supporting the
unions they are supporting the ideas of
the unions and so I don't think that
this will affect strikes and general
negatively let's talk about Deutsche
Bahn for a minute it's at least four
passengers it's a rather expensive way
to travel a one-way ticket from Berlin
to Munich is a hundred and sixteen
dollars why is it that
ticket prices are so high and yet bond
employees aren't satisfied with their
wages you have to ask the Executive
Board of the deutsche bahn yeah they are
in charge for the prizes and well we
have a situation that especially train
drivers and they they are not paid as
they should be paid and so they have
their demands and yeah okay so strikes
aren't just expensive for corporations
it's also costing deutsche bahn itself
do you think it would be cheaper for
them to just give the drivers what they
want I think so yeah okay well that's
the Union answer thanks so much for
being with us we're going to come back
to you in just one moment